>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much.
I'm delighted to be back here at the
Book Festival, one of the great--
I think the greatest Book
Festival in the country.
[ Applause ]
>> I wanna say a few words about
my recent book, "Empire of Liberty"
which is the subtitle, a history
of the early republic 1789-1815.
It's part of the larger
Oxford Project for the history
for the United States which
is nearing completion.
About a dozen volumes
and I think there are
about 4-- maybe 4 or 5 left to do.
But they've been commissioned
and that it should finally bring
to an end a project that
that began in the 1950s,
more than a half century ago.
My assignment was 1789-1815, which
is one of the most extraordinary--
if not the most extraordinary
period in American history.
I think we should start
by recognizing how important the
American Revolution is to us.
It is in my mind, the
most significant event
in American history, bar none.
It not only legally created the
United States, but it brought--
it infused our culture with
almost everything we believe,
our highest aspirations,
our noblest ideals,
all of these came out
of the revolution.
Our belief in equality, in
liberty, in the well being
of ordinary people,
in constitutionalism.
So it's understandable why
we go back to this period.
I have people asked me
at events like this,
what would George Washington think
of the-- of our invasion of Iraq?
What would Thomas Jefferson
think of affirmative action?
Now, I don't know of any other
culture where people would be asking
that about past historical figures.
I'm sure David Cameron in Great
Britain is not asked, you know,
what would William Pitt think
about what you're doing?
I mean, it just not--
it's just not possible.
So if something peculiar to us-- and
I think it has to do with the fact
that that event at the revolution
and those people who led it, are--
who created our political
institutions by which we still live.
And also the values, the
ideals by which we still live.
We go back to them
to refresh ourselves,
to reaffirm what we are as a people.
Now, this period that I'm dealing
within "Empire of Liberty"--
the term by the way
comes from Jefferson.
That's the term he gave to
what he thought was the United
States project.
The irony of course in
that is that a fifth
of the population were--
wasn't slaved.
But the notion that the United
States was a special place begins
in this period.
They're struggling to
identify themselves.
After all, they were-- by and large,
the majority of the population,
the overwhelming majority
was British.
So, how do you become
Americans when you're British?
This is why the issue of
impressment, the seize--
the British seizing of American
sailors and the ambiguity
of citizenship was so
important to this period.
James Madison, as president,
said the reason--
the principal reason we have to
go to war in the war of 1812 is
because of this impressment.
It goes to the heart
of American identity.
We didn't even know
what to call ourselves.
The term Columbia was tried
in 1792 at the [inaudible]
of the-- of Columbus' discovery.
They thought, "Well, maybe
Columbia would be a good name."
But that didn't stick,
although it sounded good
because the syllables could be
fitted into a lot of British songs,
you know Britannia Columbia
and so it so very attractive.
Samuel Mitchill who is a senator
from New York suggested Fredonia.
We are the Fredonians.
[Laughter] Well, that didn't
last either and we were stuck
with Americans, with the [inaudible]
a title that really belongs
to people of both hemispheres.
Why are we the Americans--
the Canadians have never
forgiven us for taking that title.
[Laughter] So that was an issue
running through the whole period.
What kind of people are we.
The government was contested
between the Hamiltonians
who wanted a European-type
state, a fiscal military state
that could take on the European
states eventually on their own terms
with the standing army, a big navy,
and a bureaucracy that was equal
to any of the Europeans versus the
Jeffersonians, the republicans,
the democratic republicans
followers of Jefferson
who wanted a minimal state and
wanted to use economic sanctions
as an alternative to the
use of military force.
This was the grand embargo
that we were involved
in that Jefferson promoted in 1807.
This was what we're
still struggling with.
How do you use economic sanctions
as an alternative to military force
because the use of military
force is so, so violent,
so bloody anything must be tried,
that's what Jefferson's rationale.
It's a period of enormous
controversy.
We came as close to a civil war
in 1798 as we ever have except
for the actual Civil War in
the middle of 19th century.
So that-- and people were frightened
that the French were going to invade
and that a Francophile
president or potential president,
Jefferson was leading a kind of
fifth column of Francophiles,
French supporters who
would create a--
another French puppet in the United
States that was the federalist fear.
So, it was a tremendously--
tumultuous period.
The population was still
growing, doubling every 20 years,
the fastest-growing population
in the entire Western world.
So, it's-- and this
population is on the move.
It's a period of extraordinary
democratization.
So much popularization
democratization
that at left those
founders who lived
into the 19th century
deeply disillusion
with what they have brought.
It was a-- as you know a
creative period are institutions
that we still live by, the
Congress, the Presidency,
the Supreme Court were all
created in this period.
It was a period of great
instability, violence,
city mobs, all kinds of homicide.
Homicide rates skyrocket in
New York City in the 1790s.
It was a period of heavy drinking.
Alcohol became-- we became the
highest drinkers in the world,
5 gallons per person which
we've never attained since
and was the highest in the world
with the possible exception
of Scotland.
[Laughter] These are all signs
of instability in the society.
People were simply influx,
moving at enormous rates,
migrating to the west,
more territory settled
in the single generation
following a revolution then
in the entire 150 years
of the colonial period.
So people were already
reaching the Mississippi
in a relatively short
period of time.
It was a period were
college rioting which were--
we think the 1960s were bad.
There's nothing comparable to what
happened between 1798 and 1808.
Colleges up and down the east coast
rioted, students were expelled,
half the student body of
colleges like Williams
or Harvard, were expelled.
The colleges weren't large,
be 120 but 60 would be
expelled, enormous instability.
Princeton, the National Hall
was burned to the ground
by student presumably,
no one knows for sure.
This was a period of great
instability in all areas.
Religion transformed.
The old European religions,
the Anglican Church,
the congregations were surpassed
by these new evangelical religions
of Methodist and Baptist.
Growing by leaps and bounds so
that by 1810, the Methodist who--
there were no Methodist
in America or in 1760.
By 1810, it was the largest
religious group in all of America
and growing even more rapidly.
Everywhere, there was a
popularization from art, literature.
John Marshall wrote a 5-volume
biography of George Washington
which you expected to
make some money from
and that people would read.
Nobody bought it.
They bought a Parson Weems'
short little biography
which emphasized Washington's youth.
Marshall summed up
Washington's youth in one page.
In 5 volumes, he's devoted
one page and nobody wanted
to read those 5 volumes,
instead they read Parson Weems
which is still the fastest selling,
most popular biography
of Washington ever made.
He-- Weems is the one who
made up the cherry tree myth.
That's what people
wanted to read about.
They wanted to read about
this young Washington.
Now, the generation was
filled with illusions,
so many illusions they thought
political parties where awful
that they should they
should disappear.
There should be no
political parties.
Faction was bad.
Nonetheless, political
parties emerged.
They wanted to do well by
the Indians in the Northwest.
>> Henry Knox's letters
to Washington
about how we should
treat the Indians,
even a modern archeologist
would endorse.
But nonetheless, the popular
movement was so great,
it just overwhelmed all of
these plans laid in the capital
in Philadelphia that knocks
head for treating the Indians
in a humane and civilized manner.
There were just too much
popular movement in every area.
The-- and of course the biggest
illusion of all was slavery.
All the founders, not a single
one, defended the institution.
It was so-- such a violation of
the meaning of the revolution
that nobody could defend it.
But they all thought that
slavery would die naturally,
that with the ending of
the slave trade in 1808
that slavery would simply disappear,
overwhelmed by free labor.
Now, they could not
have been more wrong.
Despite the freeing of tens of
thousands of slaves in the north--
the north was not in
consequential in the north,
14 percent of the population
of New York was in slave.
Nonetheless by 1804,
all the northern states had set
slavery on road to elimination.
But in the South, it remained
and grew, despite the dreams,
the illusions of the founders.
Now, all of them who lived into
the 19th century died this illusion
with what they have brought.
The society was much
more democratic,
much more popular than
they ever expected.
Now, before we become arrogant
and condescending towards
this generation of founders
for their illusions, we
should realize that we live
with illusions too, only we
just don't know what they are.
Every society-- every generation
I think has its own illusions.
In fact, I think history is a
record of exploded illusions.
But this leads in my
mind to the lesion--
the major lesson of
history which is humility.
Humility is the consequence
of realizing
that you may not have all the
answers to what is happening
and that future generations
will look back at us
and say, "What were they doing?"
Thomas Jefferson for example thought
that in-- as late as 1821 he said,
there's not a young man now
alive who won't die a unitarian."
I mean, how wrong can he be.
[Laughter] And this is
one of the smartest men
of that whole generation.
So, we should not be
cocky about what we know
and we should be much more
humble in our approach to the--
to ourselves and to the past.
I wanna stop there because
I wanna have questions.
We only have about 15 minutes to go.
We got a very tight, tight program
here because Mrs. Bush is coming
on board right away and then there's
a whole succession of speakers.
So, if we can open
it up to questions,
I'll be happy to answer them.
[ Pause ]
>> I guess there are
microphones here.
Go ahead sir.
>> After reading your book,
I have a question about US
and British relations
after the war of 1812.
Even during the Civil War,
US relations with Britain were
somewhat rocky because the British,
at least some British
favored the south.
But then by World War 1, we were
their allies, so could you comment
on how the special
relationship developed?
>> Well, that's a big--
I mean, first of all,
it's out of my period
as we-- we say.
But, there's no doubt that
Britain was still a principle enemy
through the 19th century.
I mean, there were people in
America who were anglophiles but by
and large, we regarded
Britain as an enemy.
It's not until the
1890s-- you're quite right.
The Civil War, we are quite worried
about Britain recognizing
the confederacy.
And Adams-- Charles Francis
Adams as the ambassador to--
or minister I should say to
Great Britain, headed that off.
But, their special relationship
did not develop until the 1890.
John Hay as secretary of state--
and it come out of a whole new sense
of anglophilia that does prepare the
way for the alliance in World War 1.
But it's a-- there are books on this
and it's a very interesting story.
But the special relationship
is really a late 19th
century development.
Yes sir?
>> Yes, I know the French
monarchy supported us
in the war with Britain.
Can you say something
about the relationship
between the United States
new government policy
and France during the
French Revolution?
>> Well, it's a very interesting--
very important question.
Initially, of course we welcomed--
everybody welcomed the French
Revolution because we saw it
as a carbon copy of
our own which it was.
Lafayette who was involved
in the early stages
of the French Revolution, he wanted
simply to reform the monarchy.
He didn't wanna eliminate
the king and he later ended
up as the victim fleeing
the Jacobins in France.
But initially, he was
supportive and he sent
to Washington the key
to the Bastille.
The Bastille in the July 14th
takeover which is initial--
is the initial event in
the French Revolution.
He sends the key to Washington as
a symbol of American contribution
to the French Revolution.
It-- well our revolution, our
republican revolution came first
and the French liberal saw that.
That key still stands or it's
hanging on the wall in Mount Vernon
and many of you may
have seen it there.
Now, as soon as the French
Revolution turned violent
and especially after
the Jacobins took over,
the American society was
deeply split along party lines.
The federalist supported
England, and Jefferson
and his followers supported
France and it contributed
to the party split
in the United States.
Jefferson never really lost his
feeling for France and he felt
that the American Revolution's
future as a republican state
in a monarchical world
depended upon the success
of the French Revolution.
So he made extraordinary statements
and supported the French Revolution.
When his colleague and successor in
Paris wrote back to him and said,
"Mr. Jefferson, some of your
formal friends are losing the heads
in the guillotine."
Jefferson's response
is quite extraordinary.
He says, "Well, so be it.
If only an Adam and
Eve were left alive
and left free, that would be okay."
This led the Irish journalist,
Conor Cruise O'Brien to say
that Thomas Jefferson was the
Pot Polof the 18th century.
Now, Jefferson never really
would have implemented that.
But, he-- his support for
the revolution was deep
and it split the society and
made the federalists feel
as if they have a fifth
column in the amidst.
And that France might
invade the United States
as it was invading every
other state in Europe
and creating a French puppet, that's
what created the crisis of 1798.
Yes sir.
>> Is there anything in the
revolutionary and constitutional era
that could illuminate such
current political phenomena
as the [inaudible] movement,
the tea party movement,
that deep mistrust of
government and law?
>> Good question.
One thing you should realize
is that the populars--
popular politics is not new.
Let me give one example from 1808.
Simon Snyder, [inaudible]
governor of Pennsylvania.
Simon Snyder was a son
of a poor mechanic.
He was self-educated, had no formal
education but a very smart guy.
But lacking all of the cultural
attributes of a Princeton graduate
or a Harvard graduate, and his--
there was no federalist party
by 1808 in Pennsylvania.
The established Republican Party--
Jeffersonian Republican
Party was appalled
at Snyder's attempted candidacy
and it split the Republican Party.
And the-- Thomas McKean who was the
former chief justice and himself,
a governor-- a former governor
of Pennsylvania called--
he and his followers
called Snyder a clodhopper
and he had a followers
of clodhoppers.
Snyder took that term
and said, "Wow,
what's better than being
a clodhopper in a society
of clodhoppers," and he rode
to victory with that slogan.
That what's popular politics
that appalled many people.
Daniel Tompkins in New
York, a Columbia Graduate,
a wealthy lawyer, he knew better.
If he's gonna win the governorship
of New York, he had to be what?
A farmer's boy and he used
that as his campaign slogan.
Not that he graduated from Columbia
and was a wealthy New
York attorney, no.
That would be a kiss of death.
So, he's a farmer's boy.
So you have popular politics of a
sort that is being expressed today.
I think in the Tea Party
Movement and Christine O' Donnell
and Sarah Palin, there's a class
dimension to this resentment
and its very similar to
what went on with what--
with American politics in the north
in the early decades
of the 19th century.
Yes sir.
>> Yes, good morning professor.
I was wondering to what extent
did religious aspects have
on driving revolution, the idea of
America as the city on the hill,
the new Jerusalem driving out
European control and influence?
>> Right. Well, I think there is a--
certainly an evangelical puritan
emphasis during the revolution
but it's a secular as well.
This notion that we were the last
best hope as Lincoln said that comes
out of the revolution, that we
were the forerunners of revolution
and that it would spread.
That's why they welcomed the France
Revolution, that this democratic
or revolutionary republican
revolution would spread
throughout Europe.
And so we supported all
of the revolutionary efforts
throughout the 19th century
with one exception.
All the revolutions
starting with the Greek,
that Latin American Revolutions,
the revolutions of 1848, 1870,
the French-- Third French
Republic, all of these,
we were the first state in the
world to recognize the new regimes.
Most of-- all of which failed except
for the Third French Republic.
There was one exception of course,
it's the Haitian Revolution,
we didn't recognized
that new a black state
until the Lincoln's administration.
But otherwise, we supported
all revolutions much
to the chagrin of conservatives.
It's more than just
a religious feeling.
It's deeply embedded in our history.
And when President Bush went into
Iraq with some understanding that--
by some people at least, that
we are bringing democracy
to the Middle East.
He was responding or echoing
this kind of tradition
which is deeply rooted
in our history.
Now, we didn't invade other states
but we supported them
diplomatically.
And individuals actually
went off and fought,
for example in the Greek Rebellion
against the Ottomans in 1820.
So that's been a deeply
rooted part of our heritage.
Yes sir.
>> Can you comment on the role
of the Louisiana Purchase.
Did it add to the sense of people
becoming Americans or did it add
to the turmoil that you
mentioned in that area?
>> The question was on
the Louisiana Purchase.
It was of course Jefferson's
wildest dream, getting--
doubling the size of
the United States.
And it was widely supported.
A lot of federalists, however,
in New England were very upset
because they realized that this
would just create more Jeffersonian
Republicans, all those states,
western states were thoroughly
Jeffersonian Republican.
So, there were some mixed feelings.
Hamilton supported, however,
although gave no credit
whatsoever to Jefferson.
So, I don't think it added
to American identity.
What was said I supposed about
it is that we didn't learn much
by absorbing these
multicultural, multiracial area.
New Orleans was a very
different place from the rest
of the United States with Spanish,
French, black, free blacks,
mixed races, and an understanding
of mixed-- racial mixture.
And the American people
didn't learn much from that.
It-- we had to wait
to an understanding
of diversity to our own time.
So, the Louisiana Purchase was
not something that brought--
especially brought us together.
Yes sir.
>> I'm fascinated by the
thought that once upon a time,
we thought we could live
without political parties.
How is it that we came to become
partisan and to think of ourselves
as federalist or republicans?
>> Right. Well, the dream-- parties
by the term is partisan, partial,
you're not thinking of the
total good and so parties
for 18th century English
speakers were always considered
to be a sign of disease
in the state.
There's something wrong, if you
can't promote the consensus.
And to some extent, we've
always believed that.
We've never really been very keen on
political parties despite the fact
that we have them [inaudible].
I mean why would we have primaries?
Why would we have open primaries?
I mean, we've always had movements
to somehow transcend
parties beginning
with the liberal republicans in
the 1870s, the Mugwump movement
of the 1880s and then the 1890s
and 1900 progressive reforms
were designed to bypass parties.
When you-- you know,
there's no European party
that would allow the nomination of
candidates to go out to the people
in general and especially allowing
in open primaries opponents.
So the parties had given
up control of their--
of the most important
function of a party which is
to nominate its candidates.
No European party puts up with that.
So parties have always been suspect.
Now nonetheless, they
grew and we finally--
it wasn't until the 1830s and '40s,
a new generation that finally came
to terms with party
as a normal thing.
The founders never did.
They always felt that parties
should be-- should go away.
Jefferson assumed that his
Republican Party was a temporary
party and that as soon as the
federalist disappeared, he--
there were monarchist in his mind.
And as soon as they disappeared,
party government would disappear.
And that was the sense that people
had in Monroe's administration.
Air of good feelings,
we've transcended parties.
The federalists have been
wiped out, discredited
and were entering a new era.
But it was not-- not to be.
Yes sir.
>> My question is sorta
along the same lines.
I'm curious as to your feelings
and what your thoughts are
regarding the Jackson party machine
and as it relates to sorta
undermining the John Quincy Adams
administration [inaudible].
>> Well, although I'm not an
expert on the Jackson era.
I think it's open to a
revisionist interpretation.
I think Jackson and his
administration are attempting
to bring back some
monarchical elements
that the federalists had
attempted to build in the 1790s.
As you know, Jefferson came
into power as president in 1800
and he eliminated almost
everything that the--
that the federalist had
built up, including the bank.
He allows the bank charter--
or the republicans allow the
blank-- bank charter to lapse.
So, all of the efforts
to build a quasi--
see Hamilton's program
is quasi-monarchical.
He will use his patronage--
within a republican framework,
he uses patronage.
He wants to build a standing army.
He is trying to build a bureaucracy.
He is trying to create a kind of
surrogate monarchical substance
within a republican
framework, because he believes
that that's the only thing that
can hold the sprawling United
States together.
Now, it turns out that Jefferson
repudiates all of these.
Jackson comes along
and what does he do?
He builds patronage, all
within a democratic framework.
But he institutes patronage,
the spoil system.
He builds a huge bureaucracy
relative to what Jefferson wanted
and he is not opposed to a
strong army and military force.
So, I think we could
see Jackson trying to--
and of course, he makes the
presidency a quasi-monarchical
as Washington had in the 1790s.
So, I think we can see that-- and
of course the president remains
as many people thought he was at
the beginning, an elected monarch.
Our president, article 2
is extraordinarily strong--
creates an extraordinarily
strong executive office.
And so I think we are open to a
revisionist of the Jacksonian era.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.